hello
[Music]
one sec i gotta
i gotta
get chat in view otherwise i can't hear
you
all right here we go
hello
okay this is a continuation from
yesterday and yesterday
uh we barely managed to overfit a model
and um
yeah
to one data point we overfit it so hard
and
we finally
[Music]
managed because i messed up a keyword
argument so now we know what the keyword
arguments are so wait a current goal i
have two
please rate that okay what's the current
goal so we did overfitting on one data
point so now we can continue
so what do we want to do
actually we want to train we want to
train the model
um and in order to train the model we
need to
uh well simply run train and i'm not
going to do a hyper parameter sweep
right here because that's just kind of
boring to watch and actually did train
the model for a bit like the full not
the full model but a thousand data
points as you can see here it took like
uh three minutes
and
this
where was it this here was the run so
you can see no actually i trained it for
longer i trained it for a while there
for about an hour i think and then some
more um
so where is the train steps there should
be training steps somewhere and that
that should go like up and down again in
any case i trained it for a while right
and it went actually down and lost as
you can see here so this model is is
doing fairly fairly okay right now even
though it's just trained on like a
thousand data points so it's probably
even over fit on those
uh oh yeah here on the bottom right you
can see that i kind of restarted it
again for a couple of hundred steps for
three epochs
but
it did train for a while while i had a i
had a language lesson
and
i just let it run i forgot about it and
i came back so now i investigated it um
i investigated what what it did what it
can do
and i have this test data point that i
made just
so the the goal is we have a question
answering data set
and we want to turn it around so in
order to create more data we want to
train a model to produce questions if we
give it a context and an answer usually
the model is given a context and a
question
and we need the model needs to find the
answer inside of
the of the context now we want to turn
it around we want to train a generative
model we give it a context and we give
it an answer and we want to it to
produce a question that you know given
the context results in the answer
so we want to sort of use another model
to create more training data
and this is my test data point right
here you can see i always construct the
training data of in like c colon and
then there is the context and then a
colon and then there is the answer and
when i input this into the model you can
see that the model responds by
saying that the question is what was
loud right so the the context is the dog
was loud the answer is dog
and the model says the question should
be what was loud it even gives the
answer itself um i don't know if this
comes from t5 pre-training or something
like this in any case this is pretty
pretty cool right uh because
you know like it is a correct question
and we were just getting garbage all of
yesterday
um
yeah so
i'm pretty happy this train now and this
actually gives decent outputs so this is
a this is one of the training data
points this is the context so it's like
about some school uh i don't even know
some main building of some school
and the question it generates is
actually pretty good the answer is
saint bernadette superiors
um
the question it generates has have
nothing to do with the answer
but
still so to what extent did virgin mary
allegedly appear at notre dum
that's kind of
to whom did virgin mary appear in not in
in lurt
it's kind of the same question right so
it kind of reproduces that maybe it
overfitted a bit on that training data
point
and then also in which french school is
a traditional statue of the virgin very
situated in front of
so you can see here
um
it's not it's not the question to the
correct answer but it is a question that
clearly has an answer in the context so
uh
immediately in front of the main
building right so that would be the
answer right here the main building
you can you can see that it learned to
somewhat generate
good questions
to
to the context we give it even if if it
uh
even if it doesn't
necessarily map to good uh
to the correct ones
so i wanna do like a hyperparameter
sweep and obviously train on more than
just a thousand data points as we did
right here as you can see this is just a
thousand data points however okay this
is not for today today i want to
continue the plumbing
so what we want to do is we want to use
this model in order to generate a data
set right
and yeah that is going to be
tasks for today let me just quickly
check
the banner right here current goal
use trained
model to generate
fake data
that's going to be
sorry
okay yeah that that is it that is going
to be that's going to be the goal right
here so we want to generate fake data
you can you already saw how we generated
data so the first thing i actually want
to do is i want to save that model to my
weights and biases like to uh
as an artifact so let me look up how
that's done
as artifact okay
um i'm not sure if the hogging face
trainer should do this automatically at
the end but if i look right here and
then i look at like artifacts
it's not it's it's not here right it
does save the code it does save the
ipython notebook but it does not save
the trained model
so what i should do is i should
i should upload a trained model right
here so
this is pretty easy
um model artifact is a 1db artifact
i give it a name type model description
and then you just say
log artifact
and you save the model to some directory
easy enough easy enough no
easy enough
we'll try it
so we'll first have to create the
artifact we already have one to be in in
here right and here the trainer told us
where it saves it to
right
at least um
train output
completed do not forget to share your
model
the where is it
we can also just look here in our 1db
this is cool about weights and devices
you just have all the logs right here
here you can see
this was saved in
whatever test trainer
and then some checkpoint
right and we also have the the model
okay so
um
can we
do we have a model.save
no
uh
save model to directory
how do we do that
yeah this this here is a lot of a lot of
plumbing
um
models
pre-trained model
push to hop
i don't want to push to hub
i want to save
i want to save it
now model outputs is not the right thing
save pre-trained
from pre-trained
okay
that's good enough
models
save pre-trained
does this exist right here and then
we're good
exists nice okay okay
so
we'll say
um
my model
all right
we did it
configuration saved
nice
and now we say 1db dot artifact
we
yeah let's just peek at the
documentation
a name a type a description okay so my
the name is uh
quest
q
generator
the type is model and the description is
generates
questions
good enough
so this is my
question generation model
okay
and now what we want to do is
add a directory
and then log the artifact
um
my model
oh
stupid me
and then log the artifact now how do we
get the the 1db dot run
does this work
yes this works
and now we should have it we should have
it
we should have it
here
as soon as it's synchronized
code code code code not yet
there we go look at that
so here's our model
uh
yes
okay
we have a config we have a model
this is pretty good
this is excellent so this is a variant
of t5 small we always know what
tokenizer to use and we can use it
we can use it as we want right
load model for inference
we should just be able to
with the same project name right
use the model load it up for inference
and then load it into hogging phase
okay
probably what we want to do is we want
to
explicitly like set the project name
right
um especially
you know since we need to be in the same
project in order to load this model
uh would make sense to
to have the same project name
therefore
or what's what was the project name
hello what's weight and bias is used for
it's used to log
all the outputs so to log your graphs
but also here to log your your models
uh which is pretty cool so okay the
project name is called hogging face i
guess that's fair that's fair enough
um
where did it get this idea from did we
set this anywhere
not explicitly but you know
okay so what we can do now is we can
generate the data set and now let's just
do the newbiest thing
there is
and just copy
just
make it can we duplicate this
can we just um
how do i duplicate the notebook
this is this is by far the newbies thing
to do
but we'll do it
so
save a copy
that's probably fine right
that's probably okay
all right
now we have hf
qa inference
okay now we can set
so here over here we would probably want
to set
the run
to 1db dot
um
what was it
init
project
okay
and so that's fine and then over here
we want to set it to
job type inference
okay
we want to quit this other session over
here
and
as soon as we're done
all right so now
now comes the crucial part right so we
have our we have logged in here now we
need to load the model again over here
so i'm doing this in two files
deliberately because you know we could
reuse this model pretty much anywhere
therefore
i want to show how this is done
uh just downloading the model and this
should be this should be fairly easy
right you can see right here
we
uh
get the artifact by saying use artifact
then we say download
and that gives us the directory and then
we simply instruct hugging face to load
from that directory
could not be easier let's try it
so
um
is it run.use artifact probably
so
and that's my
my generator my model what was it what
was the name
that we gave it g
q generator
okay so we use this artifact
um
model artifact
then we say
download
that gives us the model directory
and then we say
let's let's just print it
let's see what this gives us
nope
okay
all right
without an alias uh okay
latest
that's it
this is stupidly easy
still at it yes
this is gonna take a while
um
okay so we have the a model directory
ready right if we execute that again
it's probably still cached all right
cool and now we should just be able to
you know
should just be able to just load this
here
um
i mean
right
because that what it's that's what it's
for so we just say from pre-trained
okay it's deprecated it's fine for now
it's fine
yes uh the config i guess we can
we can
suppress this output right here
a little bit
and and
hello my dog is cute and
hello my dog is cute and cute
no
what was it so now we if if this really
overfit we expect
okay we still have the same thing
i hope this actually i hope this
actually is the correct model
so now okay we load the data set again
and
yeah we i guess we should still
the question is how do we process it now
okay
so we still have the squad data set but
now we need to we need to process it
should we process it in the same way
so now we should process it yes we
should process it probably in the same
way right
but now we should feed it to the model
in inference mode
so we have no more with no more labels
necessarily just that down here we don't
have training we simply we don't need
the trainer
we can run all of this
this is fine
but we don't need the trainer we don't
need training arguments
we don't need train
now we need a loop over the data set and
for every point in the data set we feed
it to the model in inference mode
like we do
down here
down
here
there
so x2 here is a point from the training
data set we simply want to do this with
every with every
piece of the training data set right
decoder ids
yep so
we'll do that
yep
and
let's like can we even remove the min
length or set it to
set it to something really small like
three
probably and then do sample so we'll say
for
ah
why vim
for x in
train data set
and then here in the batch decode we'll
have
uh
the predicted question
is going to be this
and we'll just add that to some data set
right so
predicted
questions
will append
and we should probably
do we have do you have like uh takadam
do we have this in here
we probably should
so
all right
so now we take every question we don't
want x2 we want x
we take every question
and we put it in
and we'll see what comes out
and we'll just do this like we'll do it
once
uh
and break just to see if that if this
works
okay
well okay i haven't actually installed
it
but
it's not defined
oh i need to import it okay
we also don't need
this we don't need to save this
or this or this
just this
nice
to whom
yep
this is fine right
so we actually have an output here
now if we just do this for every single
uh question
that should give us a data set
now the problem is that this
this data set
is just a bunch of questions right now
so if i stop this you know
predicted questions
like let's get this one
okay we we got um
first of all it's pretty
small you can see it's like cut after
some some length
and
but we'll worry about that later but for
now what we want to do is we want to
grab out the question so we're going to
do a bit of a bit of of a
post-processing
um with this
so let's say
you know after after we've predicted all
the questions we'll
um
we'll zip them together
in zip
and
we'll sort of make
a
fake data set
all right
now
the question is how
how
do we make
this data set let's first make it as
just a list of dictionaries and then we
can worry about making an actual
whatever
um hogging phase data set out of this
so what essentially what we need to do
is we simply need to replace
the question
given
the question in in this
set right
so we'll take out the
actually we can we can probably do this
up here
fake data set
okay
so the predicted question what we need
to do is we need to split it at the
first question instance
so
split
q
right this right here
let's say if it's not in
if
not in
i mean it should be in right because
it's here but
you know who knows
uh
let's just warn
i don't know let's let's warn let's um
let's logo here
is laguru nice for collabs i don't know
it's a cool logging library
okay
then
in
okay
all right logger
yeah it's defined
i know it's defined
now it's defined good
did you do a sanity check yes i did
exactly the sanity check worked and the
model actually trained
and now we are
super duper producing data
so
we'll split
one time
which will give us
uh
something and the actual question
let's overwrite this variable
oh we also break here no continue
right
and then we'll
new
x is just all of x
and also
uh
if you see the structure of the data
right here there is a
entry called question
oh there's also an id we should probably
give it a new id
right
we probably we probably should
um
there is also so import uuid right that
exists in python
how does that work so if i do
this i think it should give me
something she gave me a uuid
what if i make this into a string
good enough good enough
so
here we were
um id
let's say
let's say that is
uh
fake
and then
four
and string of that
and then question
should be
this one right here
and then we just append to the
fake data set
so now
that didn't work
fake data sets
why does it why do i append an s
everywhere
excellent so we run inference on t5 we
could probably batch this or something
like this
but you know things can be improved
later
do dict keys to see what's inside the
object
thoughts on julia language i have no
clue i have never tried it but i'm not
i i don't like language wars it's just
just use whatever languages is most easy
i hope it's not based on log4j
redeeming your monday bonanza
yes yes
so this yeah this week with the holidays
is obviously a bit a bit weak
like a bit slow so i thought about just
doing an ml news live stream
since it there's probably no editing
going to happen this week
okay so as you can see we uh are logging
a fake data set in the meantime we'll
look up how do we do
data set versioning with weights and
biases right because
that's another thing so type
raw data
e that seems easy enough
type raw data
do we have something else
not really
splits pre packager splits
add directory
you can have different subdirectories
nice
but you know
i mean we can just we we we just log
this out right
and
yeah why not
the qu the only question is how do we
save a data set such that the hogging
face data set understands it
that's like my only question how how how
does one make a custom data set
aws or google cloud for training models
on cloud gpu i don't know i don't i've
never worked it depends also on what you
want to do if you want if you just want
the machines or if you want to do
something like sage maker
i mean
i know
i
stuff evolves so quickly in this in this
uh in this area it's crazy i i cannot
keep up
so
i've i've no
no way of giving advice there let me
switch power cables around here
i have to say the the ipad pro
is like one of the best investments ever
for me this is insane like it's it's
super good at
uh
with the pen
i used to have this microsoft surface
and this was already it was okay but it
would sort of get slow over time as it
got older and
uh especially in summer
because it also had to record the screen
and now with the ipad
because i also have the macbook which i
usually don't like this kind of vendor
lock-in things but they just make it so
nice together so i just plug in the
cable and i can record in obs
and now i can just have it as a second
screen because in the studio thing here
i don't have like a monitor
but when i want to stream i have to have
like obs and chat somewhere
so
um
this is just insane it just acts like as
a second screen
and and and
even without a cable
insane i'm i'm amazed by technology
no by just how well this this works
together
right
okay so the data set objects how to
create
how to create a data set
share process load
process how to
overview
the dataset object
let's start here
uh-huh
yeah i don't i just want to create one
train with datasets
upload a dataset to the hub maybe this
will help us
so how
does it does it just take like json if i
just do json line files
do you think that's
that's gonna work
or wait let me
grab this real quick
and then
oh no we're here
let me grab this over here
because i need to investigate
the file structure right here
okay my question is
could i just save this as like a json
line file
this fake data set that i'm generating
right now how do i save it such that um
hogging face data sets is able to load
it
that's all we need to know if we have
this then we can
we can like upload it immediately
so here they load a data set
what's a data set dict
a dictionary of data sets
okay
so the data set here
load data set
okay download
or
run the loading script
csv there's csv
okay we can probably export it as a csv
no
json
that should work
okay i'm pretty confident we could just
we could just probably
get
jason
like exported as a json
and it's going to be fine
we'll do that
jason l yeah
ever try training on an external gpu via
thunderbolt no
not yet
okay i mean let's try this let's stop
this so we we have our
fake data set
it's going to be some list right of of
objects
okay the one to be back and process is
shut down that's i mean that's cool
no
why is it a list of strings
okay because we didn't append new x
obviously
cause stupid
the 1db back-end process is shut down
i mean we're we're fine no
we're fine
can we
re-initialize abnormal
program exit
all right we'll just restart
that's cool
you didn't see this no one saw this one
db never crashes ever
anyone tells you otherwise
lying
so we'll go for x in fake data set
and uh
we have to import json though
we have to import json
and we need to actually open a file
so um
import path lib2
and then we'll say
data set directory is
path
my date fake data
um
make there
uh
mode parents
exist okay is true
sure
and then will
with
path
jsonline file.open
let's call do this right
and
right
dumb
oh we can
ah no no no so we have to
we have to
write
um
dump s
we could do this more pythonic no
i'm pretty sure we could
in any case we'll just do we'll do this
for now
this could be done with like a map and
the right lines and the generator it'd
be beautiful
however
this is what we do now
okay let's
cancel this
and then we can run this
okay
apparently
wandiby doesn't like
he doesn't like what exactly
maybe it doesn't like me using logging
could this be it
now
or does it just not like
well
let's search for this
try calling wandaby.finish after
interruption
that is some advice
we'll try it
like here
make it sell
1db dot finish
yeah it has shut down we know
what if we do in it again
no
this is
this is lost now
some it doesn't like something about me
interrupting that cell right
it does not like it
maybe we don't we don't necessarily
in it what's require
i'm pretty sure
i also use it incorrectly because i make
a new experiment right which i don't i
don't necessarily want to do
i just want to to log an artifact
but what's what's require
uh
python library
1db dot
how about
save
no
log
so when we run in it
can we say some we already said that
this is just an inference run right
project
an entity is a username or a team no
config no
save code no
group no
job type there you go
ah this is just a tag
re-init
we could set reunite to true right
i guess we could
i don't know anything else
runtime restart
yes
let's do
re-init true
maybe it is the logging
like
yeah let's
let's interrupt
let's remove the logger
let's
restart and run all
and in the meantime
let's remove the logger here so we'll
just say
we'll just print here
that's fine
okay
yeah so it still allocates a run i don't
even know if i would have to necessarily
do this
if or if i could just um
use artifact
without and just say which project
i'm not entirely sure
i don't know how anything works
model management maybe
let's go to use artifact
use artifact
sure
artifact or name
maybe prefixed with entity project
name version
that i mean this
we may need we may not even have to in
it
we may just be able to do use artifact
because that might that might make sense
so now let's see if we if we break here
does this complain about wanda b again
no
we don't do that
we do this
huh maybe it was the logger after all
so now
let's cat fake data data dot
json l
cool
and we made the mistake of just removing
all columns earlier
ah
see plumbing is like
machine learning isn't even machine
learning anymore it's just plumbing
so we made we did we we removed sort of
all
all of the extra columns earlier
when we did
this
right here
when we transformed the data set
so the
here right here
i
think yeah see so we said remove columns
and we just removed all of the columns
like how about how about we don't how
about we don't do that
so well we don't do that
then what we're going to do instead is
instead of putting into the model i
don't know we put the input
ids
yep
input ids and the labels
now these are all this will already be
tokenized so we may want to remove them
so out of the
new x we don't want all the keys
we want
answers context id question and title
answers
id
question
context
and
title
that's going to be
x is it x
title
context is
x context
it's called x no yes
obviously
okay
just for making things pretty
nope
uh screw you auto format
how cold is your place it's pretty cold
this is this this is a pretty cold place
i'm sorry
this is the attic it's not really heated
but the studio is is nice here
i can set up the green screen and the
lamps and all so
okay now we should be more ready
as you can see
this looks better and let's try let's
try restarting the runtime one more time
not even not even in it so we don't even
want to in it
we simply want to say 1db use artifact
and then
just prefix with the with the
project
because otherwise it'll just create a
run every time which is
which is kinda useless no
you must call okay
well let's call let's let's do a run
then
let's make one
can i still then i don't have to do this
okay it was worth it a try
and yeah so i don't have to use the run
right here
so i might be able to just say here like
don't create a run at all
because i just want the the artifact
so now we'll wait a little bit
this is good this is good this is good
this should be cached
nope
oh no because obviously we don't delete
the columns now
and
yep let's wait for like two batches
batch size is eight
how was the recording yesterday it was
it was excellent we didn't actually
record we just discussed about what to
record
but the vid yeah i recorded some other
stuff that was cool
okay we got some data points together
and now hopefully
once the data set is written yes we got
answers we got context you can see this
here
context is long
we got question question still has the
end tag we obviously
don't want that so we have to also
remove this right here
so
as here
if
let's copy this
pred q if not pred q ends
with
this
s
huh
is it
no
ah yep
then
we'll
question does not end with end tag
and this is probably more
this is more
usual because whenever
yeah you can see right here
whenever it's too long it'll probably
stop
before it reach this
so this is this is a way for us to
filter
questions that are too long
we might also want to change that in the
future but for now this is sort of a
good
heuristic
okay
all right and if that's the case
um
we'll
split
we'll split from the right
on this
and we'll take
the first
like that
let's see if this works
yep
this works well
let's wait for 10 seconds
and then we're going to try to log it
to weights and biases okay
so
again
this looks good
and now
we'll do another artifact this time
we'll do simply do instead of a model
artifact we'll make a
a data set artifact
what was it raw data
yeah
type raw data okay
let's call it fake data
description
fake
questions
i know very very descriptive
oh no
this is
this is the wrong one
i wanted to change it here
okay add directory and the directory is
fake
data and we'll log the artifact
fake data artifact
good like that now if we execute this
what do we do wrong
you must call one to be in it
but we did
oh but we called finish
that's we don't want to do that
we want to call init
luckily we said we could re-in it
so
oh no we created now again uh
stupid
yup yup
we can probably just do this now
on macbook do you get memory leak
problems with nvidia i don't i don't i
don't i don't nvidia on this macbook
so i have no clue sorry
when i use nvidia i go to a server
okay so we've logged an artifact
let's check it out
up here raw data fake data
nice
look at that
look at that this is this is very pretty
here is our file right
okay no preview
don't have metadata yet
but
it's pretty
very cool
okay so we got a data set and now that
the final thing to do
hopefully
is that we can just take an at the the
sort of off the shelf
squad
the off-the-shelf squad notebook that we
found previously
and uh plug this in
we should just be able to plug in this
data set and then train on this no
like
let me try to break out the
question answering on squad
that's here that's a notebook right
so
let's do it
and it's probably going to yell at us
no
change type
we don't have an accelerator
so
change the other one
will terminate all other sessions
close it up
we can now do this
we don't need to log in here
we probably don't need that you do need
to insult it lfs
i don't think so
so the only point where it matters is
here when we load the data set before
that
we need to get our 1db data set in here
that's the entire thing
so after
this cell which we did we installed the
stuff
let's also install
um
1db
hey hey
yep
transformers that's fine
this is fine
this is fine this is fine this is fine
all of this is fine
so import load data set now we need to
just log in and load up
load up the data set
log in
and use the artifact
use artifact
yep
and we don't want the generator we want
fake data
model directory
perfect
now can we do like is this really
does this work
no
okay
it would it would be
okay why
why does it name it like this
can we
to the specified root directory okay
let's just call it
fake data
how about that
and now it's fake data
really
insane
look at that it just works
insane look there's our data point
crazy
i mean we don't have a validation data
set yet right
but
i mean here's some
can't pick more elements than there are
in the data i mean that's that's okay
yeah it's gonna it's gonna show
yeah let's say three
yep
nice
excellent so we don't have a we don't
have a we don't have a
validation data set
data sets let's call it what was it
before validation or valid or something
like this
train
where do we have validation
no
we don't have it anywhere
all right maybe down here
validation it's called validation
okay
so what we do is we simply replace the
tr we copy over
this is a bit immoral but
it's fine it's fine okay and then we
just run after
that's it
that's all we do
yep
all right so we were able today
we were able to
take the model that we've trained to
generate questions
new questions we were able to
train it we were able to load the data
set put it through this model to
generate a new fake data set
we have logged this model and the data
set to our weights and biases account
so now
what we'll be able to do is
what we're doing right here
and let me copy that to drive just
because
just because
i don't want to redo it
um
what we're able to do is we simply plug
in the fake data set
into
the training pipeline for squad
and
now we train on the fake data
and here okay
so
we didn't do a hugging face login
but
you need to pass in a valid token to
login
tokenizer
yeah at some point push to hub we don't
want to push the hub
right
that's just fine we don't need to
yep got the trainer train it
train train train
save
that's it
that is um and now what we can do is we
can just improve the pipeline over and
over until we get to something
satisfactory like a good data set that
will actually improve our squad
performance
yeah that's that all in in collab so far
i might do like a hyper parameter sweep
or something like this
and then i'll i'll make an entire video
out of out of it
but for now i think this is just
fine you see just how much plumbing this
is
oh no not push to hub i don't want to
push the hub
no push to hub thank
you we have an f1 of nine
that seems kind of overdone
that should not be the case
okay
so that was it for today um
as i said it was mostly plumbing
anyway thanks for being here so much
and
i don't know tell me how you like
streaming it's kind of a bit more boring
than regular videos but you know who
knows
i have to get
back and actually do something
productive
bye bye